écoute je crois pas être prêt à bosser
en solo tu doit prêter serment
je promets de faire tout ce qui est en
mon pouvoir pour protéger cette ville
je promets
[Musique]
hu
ego afoc la cérémonie
messieurs vous et vous remercions tous
les deux va falloir te cacher ne fait
confiance à personne et ne retire plus
ce masque
ils ont besoin de toi
weiss ça va avec laundering ils en
meurent après lui parle film d'horreur
j'avoue que je suis déçu hongre rigueur
du pouvoir côté coeur et roxanne mais tu
fais pas cette fois que j'ai
l'impression d'être vraiment spider man
fait tout foirer miles notre famille
n'abandonne pas chaque fois que tu dis
spider man c'est pour parler de l'autre
c'est toi spider man tu peux y arriver
ce matin
mais que saga
enfin le ca
là
charest
matin
à
ah tiens matin
[Musique]
côté messieurs